okay there we go so for people who are
joining this livestream this is one of
our infinite series of meetings about
new features and wolfmann language and
our first topic for today is a function
proposed called retry what is retry yes
so I see
it's a it's doing something up to a
maximum number of times what is the
default is if it didn't manage to do it
how does it know I see it has to have a
fail it's time to find out if it knows
whether it succeeded so what's an
example of a retry so for example it
might say retry URL read see this is
really like a while isn't it it is a
while it is made among other
possibilities now one question would be
what the default bail tests are because
it seems like there's an they're obvious
default fail test like if it's dollar
failed then that should trigger it but
what about missing or what about you
know know or something like that oh well
it should be an option not an option but
an argument you know the condition the
failure condition should be explicit in
the yeah right but by the time you're
specifying the failure condition why
aren't you just saying you know well we
don't have an until so you're saying
while it lets you unless you've not
declare a variable first of all it's
like do-while something like C instead
of while and then second of all lets you
skip defining a variable that you're
then gonna back into the while condition
okay because I see because it's giving
you the the return value okay so let's
let's look at what this would be so we
say retry what what will be a typical
action something like URL read yeah I
think so and okay fine so what would be
let's do something specific let's do a
is there something where it might not
succeed at first what will be the
minimal example here do you want like an
actual testable example like now is
greater than sometime but that's again
not really being going to work yeah what
is a testable example I mean of course
this is fundamentally about trying
unreliable thing is so yeah right but I
mean can't we simulate something
reliable with a dynamic or something I
mean we could um yeah I just have a
function just have a function call it f
and f : equals you know random choice of
dollar failed or two they have a
question about this is it distinctly
different from nest while with the first
argument being identity let's look at
that well no because nest while won't
reevaluate the expression will evaluate
it at the very beginning it'll keep
doing it it won't it won't
reevaluate it will just keep trying to
nest things and making a bigger and
bigger mess is really wait it doesn't
evaluate it it's is it hold something
well I think it says it runs f of X fur
right and then it keeps and then it it
keeps net result in there it says f of
that again it doesn't say sure expert
right but if there's identity an
expert's the thing your your read URL or
whatever nice what you say so you say
nest while identity
doesn't they read URL just evaluate to
either failed or not failed and then if
you apply identity that any number of
times it'll still just be failed or not
there's no way that that would be your
test
what expert returns with would yo no no
no that's not right it's not right
because it's the F that it's getting
redone so it's the F is the expression
that has to be retried it's
significantly more complicated F is not
an identity F has to have the URL read
in it experts is evaluated once only you
could write a hack where you make it
evaluate it in the test and then set
variables and yeah right but but then
then you've lost the game okay so but
the rough form of this would be it would
be a URL read from some URL and you
would say retry that and your goal is to
have that come back as something so
you've got multiple different things
going on so you say retry I mean that
there's also there's a question of a
time constraint also um because one
could imagine retrying up to a certain
you know for a certain amount of time
for instance
there's also especially the URL things
you might want to retry at a certain
interval because you don't like for
example if you have a rate limited
service you don't want to if it fails
you might want to wait a few seconds as
opposed to just embarking it with more
queries yeah well in fact look
specifically URL read we are talking
about having some things that involve
throttling and so on so I mean for
example retry as if if URL read is the
primary use then a more sensible
approach would probably be to have
something that says you know because
right now what we have here is a time
constraint we could imagine a retries
you know retry limit where it just says
do a bunch of retries on the URL read
what are other examples other than URL
read what are other examples of where
retry will be useful India graphics
there is a retry implemented internally
for those cases in which we detect that
a tile failed so we'll retry again but
it's also basically basically a URL read
exactly and internally its URL
read/write um what other I mean you know
there are totally other things like you
know you can have a file system
operation you know on a device or
something like that that was was hung up
but I think that's going to be I you
know I have to say I think the real
thing here would be to put a retry
option into URL read which makes a lot
more sense to me yes because the other
cases can be simulated with while having
a counter of thryce and we haven't
surfaced a single other case
realistically name another case I mean
which isn't well you can use it you can
use it as basically a bit of a form of
while where for example what if you what
if you're doing something where you want
to you want to essentially wait until
someone makes a change on some file
system
right so one way of implementing that
would just be have a while loop that
checks has this change happened has this
change happened and then once it does
it'll continue right which is very
similar to a URL read you've got a
filesystem operation which again could
you know for example our current file
system operations do not have a time
constraint in them they could have they
could even have a retry in them in other
words if what you're doing is to open a
file for example and okay the file isn't
there well we could have a notion of
retrying which we don't have right now
and what this function is suggesting is
have the retry outside but the problem
is that the error conditions are so
diverse and also unless you quiet the
actual file attempt file reading attempt
it's going to generate a bunch of error
messages before the thing actually does
the retry we're making sense I mean if
if what this said was um you know open
read for example let's say that open
read had a retry option something like
that then that would make some sense it
wouldn't it wouldn't generate our
messages and it would keep retrying look
okay I I think where this needs to go
and this is a discussion that we were
about to have with Fahim about rate
limiting is that we have a retry option
in in because I think we had a thing
that was going to be called there was a
general Association full of different
features to do with throttling and so on
and I think this should be probably a
more exposed version of that or possibly
I mean look really what this should be
is something that it says allow retries
because what this really is going to be
end up doing is saying there's a time
constraint right keep retrying for five
seconds it didn't work once try it again
that will be the typical case you don't
want it to keep on retrying eight times
where each one hangs for 30 seconds what
do people think about that we
I have the wrong group of people here to
adjust that crystal do you have an
opinion about that
I mean well you like having it as an
option like that is that your basic
point yeah but I mean also what is the
actual option it's not a count of the
number of retries that's not the
interesting option to have an URL read
well the thing is there are also so many
different failure conditions for single
functions right like for example might
want to fail on messages or you might
want to fail on the actual payload
failing alright let's end fine okay so
look let's put this in the discussion
with for him about the enhancements to
URL read etc which I hope were coming up
soon I was thinking what if I just show
those tasks there could be some free
trying need today that's true too but I
know there there are some paradigms for
like a generate and test algorithms the
only one I can think of is like BOGO
sort which is obviously not something we
really care about but I know there are
some simulations that involve basically
create a random circumstance try
something if it doesn't work try again
yes that's true but I I'm assuming
there's some sort of like some similar
system for things like system modeler
etc that used the sort of test
generation says okay I think we're we're
reaching here I think the real thing is
URLs which we all know we care about and
you know let's let's address that in
that context all right let's move on to
the main thing if we can which is array
contraction yes so this is a topic that
we have discussed other times in an ILD
and so this is our not book that
enumerates the things we have there are
a couple of internal functions with
which implements some extensions and so
I just wanted to give you an idea of
yeah
the general case of contract
okay so what is an array contraction is
you are bringing together some set of
elements in the array and performing an
operation on them and that set of
elements that you bring together might
be binary you know pairs of elements or
there might be an array collections of
elements is that right correct yes and
this operation that we perform on their
race is going to be called D so yes so I
suggest that we if you can evaluate this
example erase which has an array of
depth to another of depth for another of
depth six and we will use them for
examples okay all right fine okay so
this price is the basic operation that
takes so let's look at a to accept a 3
by 3 matrix 3 by 3 matrix exactly and
then we can generalize it to have a G
operation which instead of using PLAs
will use G mm-hmm so in many of our
functions we always use D to represent
something that by default is plus but
could be anything else yes right so the
general notion of contraction is you
take some class of index indices you
take essentially a set of indices and
you're reducing you're extracting that
set of indices you're extracting that
sub part of the tensor with that
collection of indices and then you're
performing an operation on those things
right I would say there is an example
further down but it's basically
constructing the table of all the
components and repeating indices so the
key thing is repeating indices in a
table so you have it a bit far down but
it says general construction now we
first two levels away for exactly now
what the heck is this doing okay so
let's let's look at this one first okay
so a a
for mentions three three two three okay
so the trace of that yeah by drilling
all the way down exactly and then
something curious traceless is that it
takes a minimum of dimension so the
dimensions do not even have to agree in
many of other functions we do require
consistency of dimensions better than a
four is this place so the trace debate
for is what it's the elements of the
main diagonal in four dimensions and why
doesn't the size of three why is that it
just example I constructed if it was
three three three three it would be G of
three elements but because they said to
it rather than complaining so in
principle if there was a three there
there would be it's what it is looking
at is the components iiiiii so to speak
exactly and that's the definition of
price is that it's it's always the the
iiiii component exactly okay by default
what this now it's saying contract only
two elements two level sorry it's taking
the III elements and everything else is
is it's considering the sub arrays sub
tensors underneath III exactly okay
and now the thing here I want to point
out which will be important in in what
follows is that the other levels that
were not traced we have a we have a
possibility of whether to put G deeper
in those two levels or we put it outside
so you see the levels that were not
going contracted have been left inside G
yes I understand so in some of the
functions we will see that the levels
are left outside G and then G will be
rapping directly to X right so in other
words gee you know burrows down in those
cases whereas here it's just being
applied to the complete substances
exactly exactly and depending on which
function we look at it will do something
or the other all right general concept
of contraction okay everybody needs to
pay attention here because always we
will so yeah so this is what we were
discussing before so we have an array of
in this case is 16 this is just to be
quite general and what we are going to
do is to repeat three of the indices the
P index repeated there okay this one
this what is this a you are you talking
about this one are you talking about
this none the Pearson yeah yes that one
yes so okay so in this first input that
is not evaluated this is just the
representation of what the full array
would be if we evaluate that we get the
full array rank six yeah it's large okay
but we don't need it so another point if
we want to contract levels to four and
five of that array what we simply do is
that we go and repeat the indices is the
piece there they are they index two or
four or five exactly and then the other
ones are left the I J and K are left but
you see we have to have them in the
correct order here we have to have them
tables that speak in the correct order
but there's P can be placed in any in
any position and and that's the key
question where do we put P okay I put P
in a different place here right it's
before J for some exactly what
difference does that make
yes you have to change the apply you
have to change the because they applied
you see it has to go with the position
of pin change the two two or three right
okay so now you see we all all levels
are left outside so the
here is whether we are working with a
matrix of elements or a list of lists
and therefore we will only thread
through the first level of the list so
the question here is when we work with
an array we can treat some levels as
array levels and the other levels Hasnat
array levels and sometimes this is what
you want sometimes you want sometimes
you want it to be considered as a kind
of an atomic thing then it's still a
list exactly even though it's a list
it's treated as atomic exactly okay but
I think that's a different issue from
the issue of I mean this definition of
tensor contraction here where what
you're effectively saying
so the uncontracted tensor it sounds
like the examined life for something the
uncontracted tensor has is just
basically a table the tensor comma every
single one of its indices right across
all of its dimensions so the identity
operation on a tensor would be something
like table of well I'm going to I don't
know what there's no particularly easy
way to write but I guess we can do it
with array actually we could the
identity operation is array of the
tensor sub sub hash hash amperes and
dimensions of T is that correct let's
take a look at that and so us so let's
say well we let's take your a for for
example if once so there's a for the
claim my claim here is that if I put a
four in here that is extracting the
dimensions of a for loops a four so
that's extracting the parts of a four
across all those dimensions okay great
we've got a four back again right okay
so a contraction consists of having of
degenerating some of those instead of
independently tabeling out
shove those indices some of those
indices are locked together is that
correct exactly yes exactly and that
level in which they are all together can
have a generic head can be G can be
least plus least on plus on the two most
common cases okay so what you're saying
is instead of it being a table at that
level right it is a G at that level so
to speak instead of generating a list at
that level it's like a generator to some
at that level for example so what I
could I could write this thing as a
nested set of tables but one of those I
want to replace with the sum exactly
that's why that's why we are applying G
at the level at which we are placing P
yes okay I think I understand and and
the multi tensor case there is really no
difference between the multi tensor and
the single tensor case because a multi
tensor can be thought of as a list of
single tensors that partially there is
an example at the end discussing that
the first level is slightly different
because it represents an outer product
well the other ones are just collections
and so we can we can follow this idea of
having a list of arrays but we must be
careful of treating the first level
differently okay why couldn't you have
an outer product at any level because
when we have a list of elements that
doesn't mean an outer product of those
elements but if but the first level of
list of arrays does represent an outer
product so we have we are treating the
meaning of lists
differently so what you're saying is
that the first level we've got an outer
F of a B C D for example right and
you're saying that that can't make any
sense that the at the internal in the
internal levels there's no such thing
that makes any sense why is that
obviously correct why isn't it the case
by the way did we get somebody here who
knows about the neuron that tensor
business
is anybody in this meeting who knows
about that stuff does Christopher know
enough about that stuff to be able to
represent it here not really should we
see if Sebastian
well Sebastian will be the best if he's
available or Etienne okay um because I
think that the it is not obvious to me
that you can't have an outer product
deeper in the in the you know I'm saying
deeper inside here because what you're
saying is always having a reduction of
locking indices together but I don't see
why you can't have something which
rearranges that let's see what is it
it's it's a well I'm not sure well to me
this first level this list for example
which is the list of mad Fred represents
an author product while the other lists
are just the normal lists in a ray
alright okay so you might be right
okay so in that case in that case the
multi tensor so my claim the multi
tensor case is not no different is
simply incorrect
I think this requires two different
functions yes okay fine
all right so let's understand tend to
contract so tensor contract is a single
tensor contractor function is that right
exactly but the advantage is that it can
perform several constructions at the
same time oh hi we are talking about
tensors and we're talking about the
general functions for manipulating
tensors and we wanted some neuron that
insight here in particular maybe you can
say something about when we have like
two linear layers and they're next to
each other so to speak
what is the are we at what level are we
knitting those things together like a
cata nating operation yes in a net chain
for example so in a net chain that won't
really be a concatenation it's because
that's the output from one thing if we
think about okay so naive thing okay so
we say linear layer
or am I just very very confused here so
are you talking about composition
instead of concatenation yes but doesn't
it it doesn't it effectively produce a
deeper tenser
or am I simply wrong usually is a tensor
order or rank I don't know how to call
it is the same I mean yeah you have some
yeah you have some total layers you have
some like as a change the the order of
the tensile
okay I understand but so what are those
I mean I guess if you feed it if you
feed something into the convolution
layer it can it can come back with a
deeper tenser if that's what you mean
okay but if I just simply take the net
chain of this what is that thing that
takes three it takes a vector of size
different returns a vector of size to me
like it said no I understand it but it
has a matrix that determines the that
there's a matrix okay this thing here is
the is that composition the equivalent
of a rank three tensor or something so
each individual one of these is a matrix
right - I mean it should be a okay it
will be a three by three matrix
no I understand because linear layer is
a three by three matrix yes yeah
and press some bias Yeah right I
understand but so what you're saying is
we're applying the three by two with
twice applying a three by three matrix
to a vector okay so it's not generating
a deeper tenser no effect all the way
the case okay so what are the operations
then that have so like a total layer is
obviously just doing it essentially a
trace that right
phrase I mean yes yeah okay so what's
the statement about a convolution layer
so convolution layer like a cellular
well light like some kind of block map
thing can return a different shape than
you put in
it usually return the same shape but
these things are all dot products is
that correct I mean the way that they're
acting on vectors is always a dot
product yes yes yes yes and a
convolution in a way is a dot product as
well it's like a big sparse array there
is a lot of redundancy as well right
because the same operation and but but
you have many convolution kernel so
let's say you have an image so email is
a tensor of Rank three right because you
have like RGB let's say then the first
convolution kernel will create one
matrix but a second one will get another
matrix so so then you end up with a
pencil of the same rank as the as the
input which is like a yeah breakthrough
sorry confusing ranking order okay all
right so maybe that's not relevant okay
so let's keep going here at the end
stick around for a minute maybe maybe it
will turn out just not relevant but but
okay so this is tensor contraction which
is saying level one contracts with level
5 level 2 contracts with level 4 exactly
and this function does require a
consistency of dimensions so that's why
I wrote down dimensions of a six
consistency that one five one dimensions
one and five should be consistent
exactly they are both 3 & 4 2 & 4 they
are both 4
what would happen if I repeated one of
the indices here if I said 1 5 and then
I said you know let's imagine that I
made something which had more agreeing
dimensions and I repeated one of the
indices would that still work or does
that not work know that that's forbidden
in a linear algebra so these but who's
saying linear algebra and linear algebra
would assume that their pluses and
things
yes and this function actually because
it's designed towards linear algebra it
always assumes that G is plus the only
thing that these generalizes which is
the example further down is that the
except contracting more than two indices
but the indices cannot be repeated and
when you say contracting more than two
indices that means yes it's like the
example we were seen before with AP
index so we can put P in multiple places
so we reduce three levels into one at
the same time but in the case of a of a
inner product right we have two
operations we have a + sin of x right
and in general here is there not plus
being applied in two different ways or
is it really only in one way
it's one way in in the sense that both
of those construction contractions are
both applying class no I understand that
but I'm asking within the each
contraction it's a line up levels 1 & 5
yeah so you could perform this
sequentially so so you have first a
contraction of 105 and then the result
which will be run for right now I can do
another contraction but it will no
longer be 2 4 it'll be excited might be
it'll be 2 by 2 2 & 3 I guess why
because they one disappeared
so it's obstructing well why did it
disappear both 1 & 5 disappear in this
in this thing yes so now now we have
something of rank for the results has
ranked 4 because both disappeared so did
I mention the superior they both turned
into rank into a single rank they both
turn into a single rank which is now a
right plus and very naive here let me
just see what tents are contract of ABCD
, I don't know whether I need all those
brackets but let me do both one too yeah
that's gonna turn into another okay hold
on hold on what number is that gonna
turn into let me just see if I
understand this I mean no I'm completely
confused is that gonna be I'm going
about to find out that's the trace
exactly that's exactly like a trace of
ABCD so this is requiring that the one
index and the 5 index be equal
otherwise otherwise it's throwing that
element out so it's doing two things
it's throwing out all elements where one
and five aren't the same and then it's
taking all the elements where 105 are
the same and it's combining them with
Plus exactly so what would it look like
if I just took out all the elements were
1 & 5 aren't the same so I get that by
saying trace in this case I would get
that by saying by doing a trace here
with the operation being how do I do
that I know well the problem is that we
cannot do that right now with plus d
with sorry with trace because trace will
always contract the top levels we cannot
say the 1st and the 5th god we can only
say that top 2 3 tensor contract why I
mean there's an operation here which is
plussing these together which we don't
necessarily need to do right so the
function further down which is a private
function is able to do that these are a
contract ok can I run it here sure yes
so right there array contract and now
it's going to be a 6 but is it defined
it's defined in a in a private text
context I think you have to evaluate the
first line of the network to get to that
it's it's at the end of the first
section when when it says append to that
exactly that the line okay so you say I
reckon track a six and now it's a list
the same thing least one is least one
five and now you can say gee yeah so
that's using the instead of plus okay
but the default mineral operation would
still use lists there they default here
but I mean if that was list then the
dimensions of that thing ah okay 3 3 2 2
so one in five got linked together right
and they become so essentially five
disappears as much yeah and it's placed
in position one it's that correct or is
that not correct and yes okay so and
then four is removed and placed in
position - right right two and four are
removed and place that position there
this is basic position for y so 1 5 is
placed at level 1 correct
no no I said 1 5 are placed
I'm not no well because an example go
ahead
it depends because they are placed
sequentially it's difficult to think
about the second one
because it depends on what the first one
did right but let's just take the first
one as an example okay the first one
removes level-5 because it's locked
level five to be the same as level but
it's locked the index on level five to
be the same as their index on level one
yes therefore level five is no longer
relevant and it removes level five
because it doesn't well go ahead it's I
think it could be easier to sing with it
with a G in the previous evaluation so
here well let's let's try so G with one
five here yes exactly yes so it's
placing it deeper yes so it's six levels
it's placing it at level five yeah so
it's removing actually level one so this
is the sort of thing that we were
discussing before do we keep the
non-contracted levels inside or outside
and all functions have to have a is
there a different version of this where
it keeps level one instead of keeping
our five yes try and get another
argument comma C comma so if we do comma
Phi
think it's going to be exactly the same
thing no I think this is going to
complain because the comma one means I'm
treating this array as a as a list of
other things and then it doesn't have a
level five no I think no yeah I think
this is going to place always things at
level five and then if you want to move
it you would have to do a transposition
okay
but in principle this could place things
I mean
in principle just to understand we could
have something that was something like
level one goes to level five or level 5
goes to level one that a true statement
which get rid of that level and stick it
in this level instead yes yes now this
request transposition so transpose can
do can do this in what way
so transpose can do the interchange
levels 3 & 4 for example what this is
doing is its contracting a level
yes but transpose can also do
contractions try it try the following
try trace transpose sorry of a 6 and now
let's see how this goes so we want the
first level stays where it is now the
second goes now , 3 come on 4 comma 5
comma 1 and now come on come at 2 for
example i profoundly don't understand
that ok so this is saying take level
this is a level ranks extensor right and
it's not you see the first level and the
fifth level they both go to the first
one and this is the operation due to
worth discussing before I want both to
go to a specific place and transpose is
always can contract in this way but G is
always list with transpose D is always
list does transpose have a possibility
being something different
no but the end
repeat it and then that means a
construction so okay let's remind
ourselves transpose is the list of the
kaif level in the list is the N case
level in the results so that means the
case level the level 5 for example in
the result now becomes level 1 exactly
in the answer and what does it mean
why does so then oh boy
so that's dropping elements for which
level 5 the level 5 index doesn't agree
with the level 1 index is that right yes
exactly
okay but so in principle here every one
of those contractions could be instead
of getting on every level here in fact
could have in principle an operation
done at it so in some weird sense we
could have I'm not suggesting the syntax
particularly you know one arrow G 3
arrow f4 ROH and that would replace
those lists by those operations a
posteriori yes yes so for example the
second one needs to agree with the first
one there has to say one goes to G as
well why does the third one have to
agree because these will be applied
after the first and the fifth level went
to the first level so what the women
this 3-amp just means that means that
the kaif level so that means that the
second level went to the third and then
at the third level we applied F okay
so what's wrong with that well what I'm
saying is that because we have one twice
and we are saying well what we are going
to apply at level one at the end they
have to agree the second one when do
when do
you have to once in that list yes oh you
mean the one has to agree here exactly
exactly yeah yeah that has to say it's
going to G accept no no no I understand
that but the three doesn't have to agree
right exactly yeah okay fine right so
every level there's what level do you
wind up on and what operation is what is
the combiner operation on that level
right okay okay
but that's so transposes a general is
the general function for this is that
true I mean because I could I could
perfectly well have three you know in
that transpose there if I wanted to I
could have you know I could with wild
abandon I could I could add another one
here right yeah except that it's not the
right number of information see yeah
where would be another place I could add
a one um so I don't remember what
dimensions of face exists yeah so we
were the 32 3 yes the third thing could
be a 1 so what was it so instead of that
for I could have a 1 yes but now now the
problem is that we are not feeling all
the output so you need to change the
fear the 5 2 or 4 because we need to
have consistent result yes so before we
had a 5 there we were not feeling the
4th level so it was an inconsistent ring
so we need to feel all the output levels
which are like 1 2 3 & 4
we cannot jump from 3 to 5 um let me
read again what the description is the
things in that list think 8 level
becomes the end case level of the rice
which is saying yeah yeah yeah
so those those numbers have to form you
you can't have a gap in those numbers I
wasn't
we say that in the in the possible
issues or properties and relations here
I think perhaps it is intense okay
computer diagonals of the sub-arrays I
don't think we're saying this okay
separate separate topic that should be
out of it but okay let's keep going here
okay so this is one way round now now
presumably that you could give the
inverse of that transformation yes
really well at a contraction is always
some sort of projection that eliminates
elements yes
so it's candidly inverted no no no I
meant I meant in terms of the
specification here that the kaif level
in in the list becomes the N cake level
and the result yes we can give the
inverse for normal transpositions but
for the contractions okay so I think I
think that precisely this or that in
transpose was chosen so that it could do
contractions okay all right okay okay so
now you're talking about transpose here
yeah so that's the example we were
discussing okay and the difference is
that an array contract you are merely
specifying the the levels that should be
contracted and you're not allowing the
possibility of transposing other levels
to different places
exactly yeah because this function focus
is only on contraction then any further
transposition will be done by transpose
itself if needed
okay that's super confusing because it's
kind of changed the index you know the
level numbers before it tries to
transpose I'm sure that every contract
can be generalized tools have also
transpose as a particular case but it so
every contract is this general function
which takes four arguments which take
the array to contract the the lists of
lists of indices yes the G function
would supply it and then s is this what
I call the effective depth which is
which level I'm considering the array is
a to array further levels are some sort
of atomic things so what happens limit
on the indices even given the array
contract better be above the atomic
level so to speak right exactly yep and
so these dis effective def is something
that is sometimes useful because
sometimes there have been the discussion
of how do I make lists of all functions
not to go to deeper or things I mean
we've got all kinds of nasty things in
outer to give a level exactly so these
additional numbers at the end of outer
are effective depths and outer is
actually they only function that frustum
yes right I mean transpose doesn't have
them because if you don't want to mess
with that level then don't specify it
exactly yeah and I don't know somewhere
I can track beads them because I mean it
has the same feature if you don't want
to mess with that level don't specify it
well there are some of our functions try
to go as deep as possible
like for example inner and outer by
default go as deep as possible some
others like threat or not threat they
stay as whose contract you're actually
given the level numbers right there and
contract the second argument of contract
gives the level numbers that you're
going go to right so I don't see why you
need a fourth argument that specifies
don't go down below this level number
because if you don't want to go below
that level number then don't give it an
argument too
well imagine that you want to play
basically is the level at which G is
going to be placed and it may be a bit
deeper than the levels in the
construction okay it only is placed at
that level or it's placed I thought G
was the combiner for every contraction
every one of those contractions will
make a level like 3 5 will contract will
remove level 5 and put that on level 3
yes right removing elements where the
where the indices don't agree between
levels 3 & 5
yes okay now on level 3 do we end up
with a list on level 3 or do we end up
with a G on level 3 I think you have to
specify that that's independent of
whether at the deepest level you put in
G or you put in a list which i think is
a different operation but let's keep
going to what yeah I'm pretty sure I'm
right about that let's let's take a look
at this here okay so you're saying
levels 1 & 2 we put a G so that's making
that's forcing levels 1 & 2 to agree so
it's always 1 1 or 2 2 or 3 3 right oh
boy what does flatten do now that's
something yet
so I'm just comparing the notations and
I'm saying that these notations
basically mean they do they perform
different things but they follow the
same notation yes and yeah and then
there yes
so with several other arrays there are
multiple we have several functions to do
various things and again there is a this
recontact filled with contract thread
that generalizes all of them
so let's have a look at these things to
contract with multiple arrests this is
the idea you were discussing before so
imagine that we have this tensor product
of a 4 a 2 a 4 so when my tensor product
is like outer it's like out with s equal
times yeah ok
so the mathematical terms of product
with times exactly okay so we have this
this bigger array very deep
so now we can contract on the single
array that is the outer potential
product of those arrays and then we can
follow the notation for a single array
the problem is that because we have to
go through this intermediate very large
to mess around with the numbering
because the numbering is is going to be
the result of you know folding out this
list right what was the 4th index of a4
now suddenly becomes 11 or something
yeah but the main problem is that we
have to perform this tensor product so
this tensor product is a very very large
array all right and then just to
contract it again to something small so
we go through some intermediate very
large steps so it takes more than a
second okay I understand
so the trick which is basically what you
were saying of having a list of a race
is having this inactive of tensor
product that that doesn't perform tensor
product but that's our contract still
knows what it means how wait it's it's
problem that way I mean it's it follows
the general idea of inactive that the
meaning is still there but you don't let
the depreciation going in and looking ok
that's kind of clever
ok so it's looking at a 4 and so on and
seeing how big they are exactly and and
it's doing the index you know the
addition to get to find out the 10 of
that really corresponds to level such in
such a way for ok yeah so so in this way
we can perform very complicated
contractions and quite fast I mean and
this is still rather slow because it's
all symbolic it's only a subscript
object but
with numbers this is quite fast yeah a
little race okay all right so array
contract thread is this the is this the
main event here exactly so this is the
general case so let's let's look at the
beginning where we have the five
arguments and this is it anything with
five arguments is is in do do anyway
okay let's okay so so far of them are
basically the four of of inner etc so we
have the F and G functions and F is
placed first like in your outer on
Montford yep then the list of a race we
are contracting the specification of the
contractions can be many and then at the
end we have these effective depths like
altered us
okay well examples this looks like that
different argument always know that I
mean you have to evaluate a MB which is
I guess at the beginning of this section
of multiple construction okay so that's
comparing to the other functions we have
there all the way to the right contract
thread its evaluating with staying blue
it's because it's in a private context
symbolic tensors context okay so array
contract thread starts off so this is in
the wrong order here because this is no
the first element is the F yes exactly
what that's not what it says here since
they're raised to contract oh oh I see I
see I see sir Sir sir
yes yeah if a bat bat goes first right I
see I see yes yeah that that's first
then the
they are ready to contract they raised
contract there is a contract yeah
then there will be the specification of
the levels to contract and then the plus
function why does the post function have
to be the same for all levels you're
contracting it could be different it
could be a list of functions yes I don't
think this function supports that yet
but it could is certainly different and
the notation I mean how often do we
think we actually want plus here okay
let's be clear on what this is actually
for I mean when you do tensor like you
know general relativity style tensor
stuff and you know T mu nu or RR Alpha
Beta Gamma Delta right times are you
know epsilon
you know whatever where there's a
contraction somewhere there yeah that
can be done using that inactive trick
with tensor contract but this is a
better way to do it
so what you're saying I'm saying that
that can be done with tensor contract
because that's the linear algebra case
with plus and times but tensor contract
cannot fund the general FNG right you're
also saying there's an efficiency s you
potentially unless you mess around with
an active and so on yes right well in
different ways yes I mean it's also the
case that this function or a contract
tract is it's kind of not oriented
toward symbolics while tensor contracts
are under symbolics I mean they
representing or are representing our
rules and so yes okay what the heck is
the zero there this means we are not
contracting the third array so that
means the second level of the of the
first a to the first level of the second
P - no no index of this 32y does zero
mean no index should be none instead
could be it is that these things are
handled via fact arrays of integers so I
guess that's why I chose you but does it
mean anything
no it's interpreted as no index I think
it should be none and by the way but at
the time this thing here needs to be
packed
you're in deep whatever it doesn't need
to be that particular piece doesn't need
to be packed you know it doesn't need to
okay so but because you're trying to
because you're using this thing here by
essentially positional notation to
indicate which array you're referring to
for that index
yeah yeah from what we said for taking a
leaf out of the generality world right
what we would do there is it would be
some tensor sub Alpha Beta Gamma Delta I
mean I'm it's bothering me somewhat that
we have to make this you know that
there's this sort of non-modular
connection between the list of tensors
here and the fact that every list of
contraction information has to be
essentially a shadow of the list of
tensors right yes the alternative is to
to add and as we were doing before so we
count sequentially all slots from the
beginning no it's a more grotesque I
think I mean I'm kind of wondering
whether we can combine these somehow in
the case of tend to contract with a
single tensor okay so your main point is
this case the top-level listing of these
things really represents an outer
product in other words you are
effectively concatenating the index
lists for the success of tensors rating
as opposed to in the case of just a
plain list there where you will be
introducing a single index to represent
the position in that list exactly so
that's why this first level is quite
different yeah I get it is it obvious
that that can't happen as I was asking
before on another level that that
concatenation of indices so I mean
what's happening with these tensors is
you are choosing to concatenate their
indices so the two operations that we
know we're doing here are concatenation
of indices and locking of indices yeah
so why isn't it the case that you can
have concatenation of indices confused
what wasn't it we could we could do it
but we cannot represent both things with
with a list if we do tensor product as
before that's the concatenation and then
we can put it inside any other lists yes
I guess it but I mean I'm asking the
question you know fundamentally what
we're doing is we have a but a list of
lists of indices disease and we're
asking to make certain constraints on
that list in the list of indices and one
of those constraints is to the indices
have to be equal somewhere another
constraint is that we are I mean in the
end we've got look in the end we start
off with a list of lists of indices okay
so let's call them I 1 J 1 I 1 I 2 I 3
those are listed some list of indices
there J 1 J 2
you know K 1 K 2 K 3 K 4 okay those are
indices for three tensors right so now
one thing we might do is to say okay and
out of these we want to get in this
simple operation we want to get a single
list of indices bla bla bla bla bla
mm-hmm right correct okay so what are
the operations by which we do that well
one operation is to say let's lock two
of these indices let's consider the case
of in our in the case of in a we're
locking the two in the last index to the
first tensor in the first index of the
second tensor together if I'm not
mistaken exactly we can control the
position of the first one the fifth
index fifth argument it's time for
talking about comment but I mean I think
here what we're basically saying is this
operation let's see we're locking
together two of these indices that's one
operation that we could be doing right
that in the end I see I see so they're
two things we could do with these whole
collection of indices here the case of
the outer product case is we can
catenate those tremendous ease the other
case is whether you have to agree where
we're basically adding I 1 I 2 J 1 J 2
we're basically missing together the I 1
sequence of indices in the J 1 sequence
of embassies so I 1 goes 1 2 3 4 and
then it takes over it's now a j-1 that
that's the case so dot for example would
join together what would look together I
3 with J 1 and J 2 is K 1 sure
we have a multi yeah we do have a multi
argument dot right right but that that's
okay that's the specific case of dot law
in general inner yes so inner for
example would allow you to specify the F
and G but dot is always going to be plus
sometimes I understand but one feature
of dot is that it or inner for that
matter is that it is in the end you're
trying to get a single list here and its
way of concatenated involves ultimately
your concatenation these index lists but
its way of doing that concatenation
involves tying together the these pairs
of indices here Freight and the
alternative is let's say I mean so
that's sort of a natural thing to do
looked at in this way the alternative is
put all the indices together in one big
long list of indices and now go into
that list and start tying together pairs
or triples or whatever of indices in in
that list right exactly that's what they
circle took this having already got a
single list of indices exactly okay so
the new function that you're proposing
here is this array contracted red well
I'm not really proposing it it's this is
most mostly an experiment to analyze
what's the most general case and compare
what we have to that most general case
because I think it's good to compare the
different functions these I'm not sure
whether it's too complicated or whether
we learn what's there in the case of a
let me consider what I might call a
ternary trace so an ordinary trace just
says take these two indices and lock
them together and add everything up
right in in what one could call a
ternary trace
I see it's still a single a single
combiner function
it's just that three indices will lock
together right so our current trace can
do that if the three levels are they
taught most thrillers yeah I get it
but there's nothing wrong with taking
that trace for any level which is what
tensor contract can do right yes the
difference is that now there's a
contract willing system inducing G equal
plus all right so there are two
generalizations an array contract thread
one is that it auto outer products the
list of initial tensors which by the way
syntactically we could never distinguish
a list of those tensors from a single
tensor so we have to decide what to do
that yes that's why there is a ray
contract and a recontact threat in which
there is always a list of tensors even
if it is one it has to be a list of that
sensor why is it good thread because it
it it imitates map thread mud thread is
like map
but before threading which is the outer
operation that's how is it what to me
threading is a combination of powder and
contraction because so you need to have
several arrays and then you contract
through them in the case of map thread
is at a given level so you are not nor
you cannot specify the different levels
of different arrays they all arrays have
to be at the same level and that's the
third argument of mudflat
understand that yes so much threat takes
a list of a race and it will contract
through them always at the level end of
February your character so for example
average
correct we'll have a list of the levels
of each array and 0 if that array is not
being contacted we thought might be none
okay okay what's the use case for I can
try thread again I'm not sure whether we
need the super function or to learn
which extensions would be useful in
given functions for example yeah trace
right now takes this number of the
topmost levels it take it could be very
nice to specify a list of the levels I
want to contract yeah I understand okay
but I think the bottom line here is I
think I finally understand what a rake
and right thread is supposed to do and
the answer is and you're specifying
within each tensor yeah which I am
totally confused I'm sorry I'm sorry
look in our a contract thread and the
second argument or a contract thread
that woman is identical to the second
argument of map thread identical it's
the list of a race
I meant the third argument or the third
argument yes so the third argument for
example format thread it will be a
single list and yes I get that okay but
what I'm saying is in the case what
happens if you want to contract within
one tensor
okay you're doing it a three-way
contraction okay within one tensor and
then to an index of another tensor so
array contract SEC thread cannot
contract two levels of the same tensor
you would have to use array contract for
that why why can't it do it because it's
it's contracting different levels of
different arrays that's the role of a
reconstruct thread yeah why couldn't it
why couldn't it generalize that why
couldn't it just say I'm contracting
these I mean I don't see syntactically
how to do it but why couldn't it
conceptually it could do it we would
have to have for example a list of
levels instead of a level there right it
could do it but the notation gets well
okay okay here's another naive question
okay so in tenses in linear algebra and
relativity and so on you're only dealing
with binary contractions ever right yes
absolutely plane that why why is that
why is there never a ternary case
because the contraction comes from the
action of it's linear action so it's an
action of a linear operator on a vector
and so you are contracting the one index
of the linear operator with one index of
the vector or one index of a linear
operator with an index of another linear
operator and there is the there is the
other the restriction of one having to
be kavadi and on the other contravariant
but but let's not go into them right by
the way what is the analog for our
straightforward I mean you know the
cover and contravariant thing is when
you have a metric hanging around but we
don't have the notion of raising and
lowering indices is totally irrelevant
to our kind of tensors is that true yes
yes so the the notion of tensors we have
as a race of lists of numbers or
symbolic expressions yes that doesn't
have any
covariant contravariant notion
why it mean starting from each of
objects we would have to add that from
its side so covariant and contravariant
is something that you use for more
fundamental linear operations when you
have to distinguish covector from
vectors from Co vectors
yeah right right the multiplication we
don't have okay in the case of inner we
have multiplication here right we're
doing in the case of inner we are
combining we're knitting together the
last you know level of one tensor with
the first level of the next tensor those
elements are being combined by
multiplication by default yes you know
we could have F and G general but in our
usual contraction
why does inner have two operations but
our usual contraction thing has only one
operation because with with a
contraction of one array there's always
one operation which is which is G but
when there is an outer product we also
need the F an inner is combining both
things it has the outer product of the
two arrays and then the contraction of a
pair of levels okay so you're saying
when when we knit together the things
from different tenses there is a there
is potentially so for example in the
ternary case if we're knitting together
things from three tensors yeah right
then our quotes times operation becomes
a ternary operation of those three of an
element picked from first tensor second
cancer third tensor exactly that's
what's not thread does and that's why
that's right has an F okay but there's
no notion within a single tensor of
during a times like operation is that
true no we could we could generalize it
to a map we could start by mapping
something on every element but we
typically don't do that
yeah oh boy
but for example not thread again it
doesn't have G and because it's a
contraction sometimes you do you really
want that thing in my thread what
yes Matt thread is an operation moderate
of all of our functions Carolyn system
is the one which is closest to the
general case but it doesn't have a G it
could have hoped you're saying we could
put a G as a fourth argument of map
thread right exactly which will be the
analog of the except it's the other way
round right at the is it the analog of
the of the fourth argument of inner or
not yes it is which is also the
multiplication operation
it's the plus operation G Saugus plus F
is easily one which is closer to nice
that operation would be list by default
list by default in this case except all
right so the conclusion here one earth
is that multi what is that so that's the
what levels are atomic exactly yeah
which is basically that we have these
things where you're saying here are the
tensors again it's very confusing to me
that there's no way of specifying you
know you could do it with sub lists here
within that single tensor contract I
mean you know for example we could say
here or maybe we couldn't say here
within the tenths to a contract one
three and also contract that with level
two of tensor a two and so on
yes I mean it can be generalize it's but
you see it gets even more complicated so
this is then a generalization which
combines array contract with array
contract thread right yeah okay but this
is then the general case is that correct
yes that's your more general question is
the general case right and it's just
suggested also before having a list of
G's which this doesn't support right and
the list of G's are for each successive
in that first list there here the list
of G's each one of those contractions
would get its own G is that correct
exactly which we could also indicate
maybe by some kind of rule for that
contraction which brings it closer to
the actual contraction specification
rather than yes another kind of all
these different arguments have to
correspond so to speak yes yes this
follows inner having F and G separate
yeah I understand okay so I think that
is the fairly general case all right
we ran out of all time here so anybody
who's been anybody did everybody else
like fall asleep here because we've been
talking about these ridiculously
complicated tensor operations anybody
else have comments here was it I here
okay he would surely have comments about
tensors I mean this seems like it's
correct I mean it seems like we're
getting you know we've got the general
case here whether it is and this thing
about the outer product and the implicit
outer product Inc so to speak which as
you say is analogous to map thread
it seems relevant I mean I don't know
you know the question is could we
document this general case and how
everybody understand what the heck is
going on since it's taken us an hour and
a half basically to explain it here
right so as I said perhaps it's more
useful to learn which is small
extensions of other functions we could
implement that would make those
functions well you know this function is
not difficult the sarey contract thread
we might as well have it if we're going
to and that way you know it exists and
we can special case it I mean the only
thing that bothers me about this design
is this business about the fact that
we're repeating ourselves you know list
of tenses list of contraction indices
list of functions list of atomic-level
type things that is a little weird
because we're much more used to having
things be the transpose of that where
there's a tensor and there's certain
things associated with it but I'm not
keen on having something where there's a
tensor and a rule for example and not
having the things associated with it hey
I do see your point I think I did these
this way because it follows close more
closely say array sorry I'm a threat
with a list of right now I mean again
look any of these things is going to be
fairly obscure it's fairly complicated
yeah in the actual use of these things
well gosh
so one conclusion is this has nothing to
do with anything in neural nets
and yeah well okay let's could we before
we forget how this all works could you
see if you can draft a documentation
page for a Rea contract thread I'm not
totally convinced about the name but
while we while we're at it let's try and
draft the page um and you might as well
include this case of the sub listing
thing here to do contractions within and
within a tenser and then in terms of
adding those additional arguments to
tensile contract and so on those seem
like kind of no-brainer things to do the
dance was it tres which one we had some
additional arguments yes he liked
functions in there exactly so in Mott
threat it would be nice to have a G and
in trace it would be nice to have a list
of the Leveson contracting
yes I understand
most folks fair enough seem sensible to
me I mean then the single number
represents essentially a range up to
those levels yes
recent yeah okay okay all right
well sounds good well okay this became a
bit more ornate than I had expected here
um all right we should wrap it up thanks
everybody thanks to people on the live
stream if we didn't have such a
talkative crowd today maybe that's
because we were douve to too deep into
into this what can we call it the tangle
of a sense for what we'd pass yeah
that's a possibility there's got to be a
name what do you call that in in in
giant tensor operations in general
Authority what are those usually called
that's it's a is the kind of I mean
these giant index chasing adventures
you know people refer to in
index in gymnastics sometimes yes right
right right but that's because you're
jumping from one yeah and we of course
don't have these issues here because
those are mostly a lot of those
gymnastics have to do with cemeteries of
tensors and things which is a whole
different issue here which we would get
if we had structured arrays here but
we're not talking about that right now
um all right okay why don't you try and
capture our understanding before you
forget it as well and just write up a
candidate Docs page for this in very
worst case we could put this function to
the function repository um if we don't
think it's quite understood enough for
the main system okay all right very good
thanks everybody see you later thank you